Lawrence last year last five years
played in the Spanish league
[Applause]
this last year he shot clock is off
green trying to fend off no set
look at the three that's
that's jokic a catch and fire three for
the big man first they get him in for a
week 10 days and they prepare him with
the system and we're in Vegas and that's
that's more than Mayweather did in 12
rounds so good call
cracked up with Miami in the second half
of the Season especially down the
stretch that is four he's in double
figures first in double figures on
either side with ten punches five shots
good pass Barton no kids with the finger
rolled he's proportioned well for this
game
straight away but it's very entertaining
between the Bucks Cavaliers Parker and
Wiggins
[Applause]
four-time MVP in LeBron James yeah
with Carrick Felix and denied for the
franchise we had to get it yeah and I
would have had to give him and what it
doesn't count now
to keep people impressed us the breaking
news back cut and the delivery
James the response another thing that
bill mentioned and that's how he's going
to deal with double and triple teams and
that's something that this time's up and
snares it a little fire by yourself
the other way for Golden State a little
hesitation move creating space
[Applause]
[Music]
here's Curry for three and it's good
a good show right there by Dorsey but a
feet underneath Curtis
Curry is a green Miss it's Curry got a
good handle up there
on the reverse
this young man developed a shot Durant
[Music]
right away
but how do you answer that is Duran dot
clock for the sonics
quick catch and a shot away by Durant
on his face like in dollars of tax that
Durant deal helps them out a great deal
though
Boston with the ball they made just one
field goal the last eight minutes he
does see what he does here Tatum pulls
the trigger about a 17.
I know you well enough Jay Crowder
should be like on your all Bowlers Jason
Tatum's on my all everything teams
not to shoot a little bump no call
Little Wiggles beautiful Tatum oh
has his team loose it's the first loss
by a USA basketball team at any level as
Tatum knocks down
three seconds to go Tatum launching it
counts who will say how'd that guy miss
it well sometimes it's not his
responsibility you got to know whether
it's the trail of the contract it's two
more roster spots roster spots go from
Phil's beautiful blocks that Tatum they
didn't break a sweat and go have a seat
young fellow always crossed over by Paul
George the leading scorer for the Pacers
they get it to George though drives
reverse layup good and the foul
Nick Roberts the law passing the Finish
By George
Roberts gets it to George driving
Baseline on Hayward Hayward leaves his
feet and it's her on a run out McRoberts
to George oh yeah 3D Hayward had just as
much room as rice did he didn't take the
shot rice did George does it's a 6-0
Portland run get them back within four
there's Devin Booker he knows when to
take the back seat and went to drive and
forces will uh he's unlimited you see
him cutting down the lane great another
estimate in the post we don't know he's
like he's a competitor he's not really
quiet which I love his vocal and I love
the fact that he fouls very aggressively
see the pulse game
occur in the post on Montero back to
them
Brown has it
Phoenix on the move up by 11. oh okay
okay has the feeling okay six in the
fourth now for Pierre Jackson
oh somebody got to call these screens
out kachinsky on me
after
two years ago having a pretty good
season
they look at Jared Dudley as
knocks down a long range Jade it's USA
Basketball the next week and a half
you talk about a learning Memphis
Grizzlies DeMar DeRozan making the drive
from Southern California
and there's the first field goal as good
as the players were that followed him
Williamson inside
[Applause]
fluid inside
Robinson tapped it out to knock Zion
rips it touches it home
my goodness noxy just takes it right
away
or maybe not
okay for your contract
coming over
here
in the depth charts for the Golden State
Warriors Steph Curry and David Lee said
knowing you know the Tobacco Road
everybody knows you guys score but just
talk a little bit and tell us about the
team believing in Casey and that's why
they're being successful well I will say
what changed in that Series against
Golden State as you see the steal from
Gilda's Alexander that motivation and to
keep things fresh
so now you've got two things nice move
they used to stay healthy and improve as
a player
push for the High Flyers yeah
oh
this Alexander to the rack
Houston yes now to see those guys leave
and now they'll talk about maybe Melo
coming in gilvis Alexander working on
Melton to the hole over league
basketball a season ago and according to
the John Waller team that can't get
enough wins who did not start today for
the first time in the summer of these
beautiful passing sides this is a nice
matchup on top Weber a great defender
Murray was nice left-handed you all the
best next season with the Denver Nuggets
here's Murray on neutrality and that's
certainly something that Mike Malone
brings to the Denver Nuggets it begins
USA going to have a couple of tune-ups
and they'll play here in Las Vegas to
get the guy cutting put your opposite
side of that lane you got to step over
and help stick your hand in there
Mark that down oh
[Applause]
young man when it came to finals filming
on NBA TV during last year was he
sporting the beard in the Personnel
decisions but when you first heard about
the possibility of Dwyane Wade coming
from Denver C is that it shows the
commitment that Josh Proke and Tim
Conley they're willing to do Matthew's
on another wing and then you have
Lamarcus coming down the middle
oh
[Applause]
the second tier guards he's going to
have an impact Lillard excellent pass
excellent finish Lillard
shifting to his left and you can see the
hard dribble with the left boom now it
comes to Lillard slancy and again going
to his left right to the cup later right
to left that time for Lillard here's
Lillard off the screen from Leonard
Damian Lillard the other way Blows By
Millsap puts in the right hand it
becomes pretty easy and you know
Vinnie's a great recruiter so he'll get
it done and Andy understands you know
will you please get out over to the
powerful
Runner he landed with both feet on the
table not one young there's the other
day he was hands on he was energetic he
was positive
Atlanta was held to 12 first quarter
points
Trey young another long four
there's the steal on the run out young
dishes that's what I think you have to
do you got to go
search and seek out wisdom and ooh that
is deep come down score and make a play
I don't know there's not a lot of big
Trey young up top
it's what has to shift defensively yeah
I think just the mindset and you can see
there's a sub and one that seemed to all
you know kick their teeth in against
each other right but you know what look
I think it's exciting in the skill level
showing how much more pressure it puts
on the defense Mitchell good looking
jump it gives some of these guys
especially the marginal guys that are
from an athletic family his dad a former
baseball player and On Cue and culture
is both he and Tony Allen
yeah Wayne Hunter couldn't finish and
here's Mitchell Mitchell good on the
push and one
how about Donovan Mitchell 25 of his
teams 59 points and eight of their 11
Steals and now 27 4.
[Applause]
Mitchell's slammed on the brakes